[Music]
sighs is it life-size I think oh you
know what's amazing about this is that
it's actually life-size for a pickle hey
this is Dan Harmon and here are the most
viral
Rick and Morty moments or Rick and
Mormons turn myself into a pickle Morty
boom big reveal I'm a pickle what do you
think about that I turned myself into a
pickle
I'm pickle Rick I remember being in the
writers room and I remember someone
saying Rick turns himself into a pickle
I do
just remember kind of immediately
leaping on it and saying well because
that sounds like such a dumb innocuous
thing like why would Rick do that and
the answer has to be the most complex
thing the concept for the episode really
is the entire first act as opposed to an
idea like Morty makes a robot the idea
of pickle brick really was everything
that you see in the at least the first
10 minutes of the pickle Rick episode
the way I was thinking about it was it
was thick the RV breaks down in the
desert episode of Breaking Bad these
cool episodes where you take an icon and
you say well what makes them tick on the
inside and you do that by depriving them
of of everything and then you so you
learned so much more about them pickle
rick has said it's great emblematic of
what I love the most about rick and
morty because my partnership with justin
gives me this really fun license to go
yeah like let's take this really dumb
thing incredibly seriously i took a
really freeing thing he just retains his
innocence about stuff like he just likes
what he likes and he just has these
thoughts that are crazy and childish and
treating that as if it's as important as
a nuclear power plant is like my
favorite activity only at the very end
of putting the script together realized
that there was only one reference to
Rick's drinking in the entire episode
even though the idea of being pickled
and the actual metaphor itself is like
that episode is so much about alcoholism
and yet it's the only episode of wicked
Marnie where the words alcohol or
references to booze are completely gone
because I noticed that right at the end
and pulled the one reference to to him
being an alcoholic out so that it's it's
like this pure metaphor the fan reaction
to pickle Rick I'll always have a fraud
complex about because we teased it at
Comic Con and everybody that loves Rick
and Marty knows that you have to wait
really really really long periods see
like Rick and Marty so I don't know if
we cheated by showing a clip of pickle
Rick as an animatic at Comic Con and
then if you love Rick and Morty all you
could do was think about pickle Rick for
like a year
maybe that's cheating I don't know so
it's like that then the episode happens
and it's like all red clay as long as it
didn't suck that episode it was gonna be
a hit maybe but that's like that's what
writers do themselves they trying to
figure out why they suck the courtroom
transcript
I don't care I know you don't and I
sentence you to 20 days for that and if
you say anything else I'm gonna add 20
days for everything you say you forty
days you again 60 go yourself a year
your mama
ten years suck my something this is
gonna be an interesting trial I woke up
one day and checked my phone I think it
might have been a guy that works at my
animation studio starburns head dropped
into a group text this transcript that
had gone viral already just the
transcript of this crazy court case so
when I got to work it was the only thing
I was thinking
about I wanted to impart to everyone how
insane it was and then that turned into
two writers reading it out loud and as
we were reading it out loud to the
writers room I think that's what Justin
walked in Justin's enthusiasm for that
thing just took over and that was the
Latin that's the only thing I ever had
to do was be fascinated with that thing
as a text message I will murder you your
whole family your kids I am not supposed
to be in jail I was framed
that mother asked me to eat his ass for
a bag of coffee the guy that leaked that
that transcript I think emailed me and
said hey I'm the guy that put that
online do you want more court cases the
answer is I don't know are any of them
ever gonna be that insane again and
probably not so that and the next one
would be about a fender bender maybe it
would be great I don't know the Carl's
jr. thing Justin said is it okay if we
do this and I was like yeah if you want
to make cuts go ahead and he did like
yeah there was all these notes going
back and forth and one of them was the
burgers aren't allowed to say anything
funny I can't remember what it is but if
you watch the commercial and listen to
what the burgers are saying I think one
of them is saying like I'm not funnier I
have no jokes characters thickburger el
Diablo
[Music]
the introduction to the world of the
word schwifty
big audience with me you gotta get
swifty in here it's time to get you in
get schwifty it's our world's best
effort that's what the beginning of that
story is justin was doing voice work for
a video game version of Rick and Morty
one of the items in that game is summers
iPod Justin therefore recorded think
five very improvised like free flowing
music tracks to be on summers iPod huh I
wonder which one of these songs is gonna
be the most effective tool in which to
wake him up with
[Music]
so those were on mp3s that I I heard
them and for the next like several
months everyone kept saying to Justin
like we have to do something with this
stuff and I think we just came up with
the idea of well let's what if the whole
episode was about music in some way and
I can't remember who's pitched the
American Idol planet was truly that
episode was built around the excuse to
to do get schwifty it was written
backwards from the moment where they do
get schwifty kind of a fickle I'm
worried about no earth blowing up man
what why not
yo this is why yeah there's a thing
about the the ice-t thing I think I'm
allowed to say this and it's a good
thing there's a weird aspect to doing
impressions of people which is that if
you just do it it's okay because it's
parody but if you ask them to be on your
show and they say no and then you do an
impression of them it's called ripping
them off and they can sue you I really
want to say to ice-t like who I know saw
the episode cuz fans sent it to him and
he was like he was like man these people
are on drugs or whatever like he I think
he liked it I love ice-t and like I
would like it would be a fantasy come
true to like have him come and do ice
tea or water tea or any other character
he could be vice president or whatever
like it would be great to work with him
sometime I I love his voice like that's
why I do a dumb impression of it my
store
begins at the dawn of time in the far
away realm of alpha be trium their every
being is a letter of the alphabet but I
was frozen and exile to the cosmos by my
elders as punishment for not caring
enough about anything ice tea
this is my missus my personal appeal to
you please come to a voice for Rick and
Morty the surprise season 3 April Fool's
Day premiere people had been waiting
forever for for the premiere of Rick and
Morty there was no date announced ever
and and then on April Fool's Day it
started airing just the the new episode
of Rick and Morty with absolutely no
promotion and no no announcement was
just airing an Adult Swim I think this
is about the third or fourth time that I
heard an idea from Adult Swim leader
Michael as know that I just thought this
is a horrible idea
but the previous three or four times
that had happened it Lazo is always
right because for a year I had been
suffering a lot of kids tweeting me
going like where's the where's the new
episode where's that where's the new
season and not being able to say
anything i I did get to give me license
for one I got I got to pick one kid
waited like five minutes before the
premiere and he tweeted me and said come
on where's the season and I responded to
him going like what do you want me to do
wave a magic wand and just make the
premiere of Rick and Marty happen just
cuz you asked and knowing that he'd go
yeah I do and I'm like alright you get
this one turn on your TV and I have a
feeling that kid's gonna grow up to be
either president or a serial killer the
goodbye moon men song we created a
character that was a gaseous cloud that
would be named for it was like an
omnipotent kind of all chemical being it
was pretty standard story breaking stuff
the whole writers room coming up with
the idea
that if it engulfed you it could get in
your head and that the way we would
represent its friendship with more tea
and bonding with him would be like a
cool music video went from that to
cosmic went from cosmic the David Bowie
I think that's probably the seventh time
David Bowie was asked to work on
something that I had ever worked on
because who wouldn't want David Bowie
you just expect to know and we got it
and moved on and I that made me think of
the flight of the conchords they had
their amazing David Bowie song where
they did dueling Bowie's and their thing
I was like let's just get one of those
guys two should do it that's pretty
pretty pretty basic stuff sitting down
for this is the first time I heard of
the these covers of that song so I'm
actually really excited to go dig them
up
I like that it was it hombres lunara's
is that is that the approximate
pronunciation Bray's Luda raised at such
a way more beautiful title and wait wait
oh it's a it's a yeah so is it was the
full title arrivederci hombres alone
Aires
[Laughter]
[Music]
it would be a crime to not mention Ryan
elder the composer of Rick and Morty for
yeah I mean that's he you know creating
music worth celebrating about the
dumbest stuff in the world all the time
evil morning fan theories I have never
read a single one of them
I let fan theories trickle back to me
because you've got a room full of
writers you chitchat there are people
who are less afraid than me of going
into the subreddit
so I sometimes things get back to me
about like certain theories about Rick
and Morty in general and then I imagine
there's a million evil wordy theories we
have fan theories of our own in the
writers room
they're called ideas that go in a shoe
box like we have these discussions but
we don't we don't decide anything that
becomes canon until until we have to I
don't consume record Marti fan theories
because that would be a bad idea what if
I saw a theory that was real it would
eliminate me being able to do something
that I was cooking up because I'd go
well that person guessed it and even
worse like well do you want me to steal
your fan theory and use it as an idea
Wubba lubba dub dub is pretty funny
origin Rick goes into like a kind of
like fourth wall breaking conniption fit
and he goes down to the ground and
starts like hamming it up ryan Ridley
had written into the script
Rick parentheses a la Curley for you
kids out there there was this guy named
curly and there was this thing called
The Three Stooges it was like there was
this thing where curly would like go
down on the ground and like run in the
circle on the ground and a clockwork
fashion and go so Ryan Ridley tried to
represent that in text vice by typing
maniac Justin roiland who may or may not
have been drunk or in any case is Justin
like he he just he's just riffing
through
the lion Samee he he read it as wobble
of a dub dub which we thought was
hysterical and and from there it just
became yeah it became the thing that he
that's my catchphrase remember it's a
monument to catchphrases we're part of
the problem well point yeah that's a
problem I don't know what I'm the most
proud of is something else I think Ryan
Ridley wrote which was that's the that's
the follow-up to it which is after brick
has now said wobble of a dub dub a few
times is finding out on the finale of
that season courting a bird person
that's bird person language for I am in
great pain please oh my god oh wow did
you mean I am in great pain please help
me that's insane and can you explain to
me is that something that they
intentionally did at the switchboard at
Google or is that the result of either
there's like Oh someone at Google is
like a huge fan that makes me go I
should tweet less because when you have
that much influence over the people that
control the government you should just
hang back and like I could like like why
am i tweeting about my politics
I should like sit in my bedroom and
think about how to influence everyone
[Music]
the videos that I see on YouTube whether
they're remixes or theories or analysis
of stuff and record morning it's it's
it's amazing I know it's a dumb meme the
the it's representative of a bad thing
but that that meme of like to be fair
you have to have a very high IQ to
understand Ricky Moore on one hand
that's emblematic of like bad elements
of fandom but on the other hand like it
does make me proud it's a show that is
clearly loved by among many other people
some of the most creative funny smart
people available to view your stuff like
it's it's if it makes you feel like you
did something right it's great
[Music]
thank you for watching those incredibly
viral Rick and Mormont's no you didn't
watch them you watched me talk about
them
thank you for watching that you actually
are owed more gratitude for that because
how is it entertaining to watch someone
talk about things that are entertaining
I digress
if you like the show keep watching it if
you don't like the show force yourself
to keep watching it whether you watch
the show or not buy some of the
merchandise and if you make the show
share some of that merchandising money
[Music]